you don't get to do a lot of spots in
this well guess who that's for trick
fingers in it but you will into
freighter
how excited are and how much pressure is
that taking on a role that not only
people love the video game they loved
Angelina Jolie did you might try to kill
me I'm not gonna kill you
I said you'd try for me I was at well
Angelina Jolie is the icon of true lara
croft or any one of the main that the
thing is a babe leave into the game 2013
and view game came out two years ago and
historian and the right is to the game
won a lot of awards and it's more of an
origin story both gonna try and push to
make something new have you started
training are you getting in that mode of
like the fighting all that stuff I
haven't started to about your head to
toe soft are your hands go soft
no I mean III said that they excited to
maybe go to the gym every morning but
I'm finishing up a big Bendis movie
which is very different and also I'm
doing another European drama called
important no organs sewed still quite
good to go it's
we will start shooting him later
thoughtfully so you have a minute - you
have to get it